ce lundi à beyrouth la jeunesse sait
rassembler comme souvent depuis un an
l'enjeu du jour est d'obtenir que les
droits d'inscription de cette
prestigieuse université privée
n'augmentent pas face à l'effondrement
de la livre libanaise
la direction de la faculté souhaite
faire payer l'accès en dollars avec un
taux de change calqué sur celui du
marché noir
nous sommes venus ici pour réclamer nos
droits pour dire que les étudiants ne
paieront pas le prix de la corruption
nous sommes des ja en livres libanaises
et ils veulent que nous payons en
dollars nous allons continuer à
protester au liban en 2020 60 % de la
population vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
c'est deux fois plus que l'année
dernière l'explosion dans le port de
beyrouth l'été dernier a porté le coup
de grâce à l'économie libanaise
c'est là qu'entrent est 80% des
importations du pays
le marasme général inquiète jusqu'aux
nations unies
le système bancaire et financier
libanais est en ruine la paix sociale
commence à s'effondrer
l'insécurité augmente les fondements du
liban se dérobe et les dirigeants
politiques semblent attendre ben hayden
mais c'est le libor pas les états unis
avant washington c'est emmanuel macron
qui a tenté de soutenir le liban sa
tentative d'imposer un remplacement
rapide du gouvernement démissionnaire en
août dernier est resté sans effet
faute de consensus l'exécutif n'a pu
être renouvelé
six mois plus tard il est toujours au
pouvoir